- Because my last
boyfriend had been Irish,
and in Ireland, we practice
this ancient mating ritual
called sneering each other.
And I mean it's very hard to
tell, some people are like,
how do you know if someone
Irish is flirting with you,
or just being genuinely
abusive towards you?
(audience laughing)
And the answer is, you can't!
You just can't.
So someone will be like, oh my god,
what did he say to you?
Well he said to me that
I was probably barren
because I've been ridden
around the town that many times
I was like the village bicycle,
and instead of eggs I had like tumbleweeds
tumbling through my womb.
(gasping)
And what did you say to him?
Well I said to him that
his penis is so small
that condoms won't actually fit over it,
so instead what you have
to do is if you take
a vitamin E capsule and cut it in half,
and then squeeze out all the oil
out of that vitamin E capsule,
and then put that over his penis and even
then you'd still be able
to fit your pinky around
the circumference of it.
Oh my god, and so what's happening?
We're moving in together,
I really, really like him.
But in America, you
guys are such a weirdos.
Someone came up to me
in the middle of the day
in a coffee shop, and he
was like, hey, how are you?
Sorry I just heard your
Irish accent there and I,
my grandmother was Irish,
and I'd love to talk to you sometime.
Sorry this is too forward
but there's my number,
you're under no obligation
to ring me at all
but I'd love to take you
for a coffee sometime.
And I'm like, what?
It's the middle of the
day, I'm completely sober!
We haven't even had sex yet
and you're asking me for a coffee?
Fuck off you rapist.
(audience laughing)
It's so weird, it's so weird.